es gibt sehr das thema sehr an gemacht
wo einst sie dann ihre zimmer mir stelle
dies gemeint sie schrecklich vor
aber wie es für die betroffenen selber
ist aber es ist auch nicht jeder seine
eigene welt
[Musik]
machen sie mit abschlägen sie immer
richtig durch wird hertz umso wichtiger
ich bin 23 und lothar menschen mit
demenz
[Musik]
das sind sie mögen also zwei ringen wie
genau sind eigentlich alles was 210
genutzt werde momentan 110 euro aber aus
einzelnen clubs wird und es hat sich
alles an zeitlosen seien sie auch noch
[Gelächter]
so es ist also sie sind auf zu staubig
ohne da wo einst sie dann ihre zimmer
aber aber mehr zeit ist es ihres teams
ja ja wohl das tieres juni vorgestellt
dass ich seit ich nehme geschieht dass
ich nichts wofür das ist billig habe ich
gelacht orientiert war richtig die
richtige tür mit tommy kind also sowieso
schon schwierig für mich und ich habe
jetzt auch lieber von harmonie aber dass
er vielleicht auch hier bis 110 gramm
begriff bezieht sie sind einstellbar ist
mit drin
das hat ist das nicht stimmt wir stehen
bis zum richter
gerade mal als erstes lernen die auf der
heiligkeit wo viele am anfang hier im
wege 12 leben dort sein und thailand
alltag so kurz nur gut halb so viele
wohnen im garten moment im redstone
frequenz nicht sehr schnell dass die
bohne fesselt ehrung werde ihr am tisch
dieser wie sie 23 kaschuba sie hat zwei
erwachsene sind wurzeln in bosnien und
geraden tuma weh tut aber auch andere
bewohner schnell ins gespräch
dass viele frühere präsent ist dass anja
wartet was mir aber überrascht ich wie
unterschiedlich sich demenz bei jedem
einzelnen zeigt
[Musik]
das können dann machen sie redet merkt
man doch selber ziemlich versteckt
[Musik]
demenz ist vielmehr eine brille moment
verwirrt ich bin doch sowieso
jawohl das ist ein böhmisches dorf
roddick steht dass das klar gelb hat
sich so vieles sehr ungewohnt
die hardware ist das machen was das war
für die demenz nicht nötig oder zum
tanzen es schon dass manche straße aber
gleich es gibt es schon maden dienst
wird zum beispiel das thema finden oder
es gab es zum beispiel dass sie mehr
erreichen
der komplette gefordert war also etwas
wie zum beispiel das richtige stelle
also temperaturen stelle von wasser bis
die richtige mittel aus zwei das gleiche
sache war alles ganz simpel dass ich gar
nicht vorstellen was man dauert einige
stunden also besser das ist aber so
drehen sie erst verständlich sind aber
was sie einfach zu teilen übrigens aber
ich bin auf einer relativ ruhigen tag
seit dem 17
dafür sei jetzt dass der hl
es gibt sicherlich sehr irritiert so
eine frage war gefordert 10 mit der
antwort
wo aber so wie es stimmte bis nichts
aber das schulter für ganze hand wieso
sie da sie ist und den verletzten das
verletze nicht falsch
kino frage loni zukunft also besser sie
menschen dort meter vor
wenn man einfach teilt was nur gott als
überdrehte was von der [ __ ] gegangen ist
[Musik]
marjorie mittagsschlaf lieder
heute schon weit trifft überall bewohner
alle türen sind bewusst offen
liga wir sind auf dem wege abteilung wo
menschen mit demenz seien die wohngruppe
jetzt kaffeepause und begleitung sagt
gestaltet
[Musik]
auf der pflege ab der heiligkeit
menschen oder ganze dafür und linke
bliebe der tagesstrukturen strom umso
wichtiger war schumacher direkt über
politische und sozialkritische die
hilflos stockumer und weiß nicht so
recht wohin mit mir
sie ich ganz gut merks sagen jetzt hast
du etwa eine waschmaschine
persönlichkeit und sie nie würden boni
dass du ihn quasi wissen zwingen
ich bin jetzt 6 christian ziege und ich
versuche mir einfach immer zu überlegen
wie wir ich jetzt dass wenigstens wille
war da war ich hätte mein geschäft so
dass sie wirklich sagt ja ich verstehe
jetzt wirklich und ich finds auch ganze
unmögliche situation aber mitten am tag
ich brauche hilfe
ähnlich funktioniert ist will ich glaub
ja ich staune immer wieder wie die
menschen einfach eine ganz andere ebene
doch einfach glaube ich das gefühl
verstärkt sich luft auf
du hast einfach zu ihrer als bieten so
[Musik]
naja fit
in wahrheit geht schubert riskio und sie
gilt europaweit als pionier in der
betreuung und pflege für demente sein
ich privat aber zu eng noch ferrari
[Musik]
was in ihr dorf für den salat firma
übrigens gut und nativer stein ließ von
angehörigen nie mit dem fernseher
anmachen abräumer war ausdruck der ganz
neue bedeutung über für mich
eine zaubershow machte beugen sie und
ihre frau simone und dynamik setzt und
in dem moment wo man exzesse sind ich
sehe ganz wahnsinnig strahlen noch 77
und ich aber vom spiel
[Musik]
dass ich das probiere was da sich die
siemens wäre
rund zwei drittel vor der demente
menschen leben im heim sondern die high
dieses für die angehörige irgendwann
einfach nimmer gut minister momente wo
sie müssen entscheiden sie ihre frau bei
zingsheim unternehmen die haben ja das
ist das hat sich langsam entwickelt das
projekt so langsam gemacht und das ist
doch normal
250 und also irgendwie traurig ist es
einfach nur noch vorhand pflegeschnitt
zuschlägen sie ob sie hat mir die hilfe
der verweigerer verhält oder hat die
möbel des und denn jetzt langsam
schwierig das weiß ungefähr bis auf 35
jahre oder noch länger
[Musik]
wie demenz ist eine person krank aber
ganze familie betroffen
das ist schick wachse so mortara der
absuche berühmt für ihre tochter barbara
köhler
[Musik]
bevor mein erster tag in weiz ein gott
nur kino auf der oase für menschen mit
schwerer demenz und das nette boni
einzelzimmer zum inneren überrascht
liegen sie zwar in rom
[Musik]
am 7 treffen ist um magere bord es ist
offenbar einiges los war und kurz morgen
esse
[Musik]
der frühaufsteher
für dir deine idee rose verschnupft
das bild von einem menschen
alicja immer große ruhm ist mir
übernachten hofgang michael schmid
wir hätten da krankenversicherten mir
ein früherer in unserem altbau ein
fleckiger da war 12 platz und dann
möglichst umgang der renovierer und
etwas mitmachen und dann haben das
personal gefragt ob ich etwas will tier
das man macht mit denen menschen oder
sind alles machen aber keiner zimmer
bucht oder jede für sie individualität
war der gedanke mal was erlebt ein
mensch im hochwald hoch ein alter
mittelschwere demenz mit sehr schwerer
demenz erkrankung und hand merkt er
erlebt eigentlich vor allem nur noch
gruppe also wenn man mal ein paar
hundert video drucken der menschheit
immer in der inter gemeinschaft kleid
und sieht 50 60 jahre heinz kühn
jetzt kommt einer zimmer ist jetzt die
errungenschaft der menschheit
der mensch ist wenn er an cent kommt von
seinem laptop wie hat also nur irgendwie
immer sozialer bezug fehlt ist und dass
sie menschen auf dem weg und wir glauben
dass die gemeinschaft hat der große
sicherheit gibt das ist das wichtigste
was muss man lernen im umgang mit demenz
mit demenzkranken menschen
was sich das was man kümmert bezirk
unser yorker egal wie ist egal ob das
essen das norm verständnis ich mir lidl
bietet ja immer drunter dass menschen
mit demenz und renommee hand und enormer
heißt das konzept auf der bode uriniert
jetzt kommt wo mache ich es kaum autos
oder vorerst aber blöd dass das passiert
ist ein fußweg also da passieren ein
jahr ganz kuriose geschichte
ja das haben wir bei gartenkunst und und
und dann hätte das immer mit so dass ich
sage ich gebe es bezirks angebot und
bewohner hat damit die möglichkeit sich
sicher viele will er fühlt sich nur noch
sicher über bezirks menschen also zum
schluss da blieb der mann alles von new
york logische denken und alles
emotionale
heilbar ist demenz mit 1000 platz das
sind tonfiguren wo bewohner selber
gemacht hat jeder erinnert an ein mensch
er ist ja schon mal zwei fachmagazins
mit simon warcraft auch wenn es jetzt
aufstehen gibt ob du jetzt könnten wir
bis wann sie warnt dafür dass auch lob
von ganz ganz einfach werden dass wir
die zwei diebe sehr interessant dass ich
irgendwie war da
[Musik]
am moorweg noch unscharf und barbara
schupbach wieder ihre top suchen familie
hat früher auf die ganze welt bleibt
[Applaus]
sieger war ich froh dass ich mir auch
gestatten singen das lied hause
verbracht und sicher vor indonesien ist
der punkt wo du für die vorbereitung und
den bruder für die mutter mir sind
entscheide dass sie dort wie sie während
der osterferien dass das vielleicht eine
möglichkeit ist dass sie mal wie sich ja
und dann ist genau eine woche bevor ich
bin schon situation passiert die hey was
sie erwartet evonik dass sie weg grant
ist und nachbar oder nachbarin zidan im
zentrum kunde und sich um hühner können
mit ihrem teil von mir alter und sagen
was man isst ernannt und hört und sich
an immer high und dann noch nicht im
ersten moment an christ was machen denkt
ich jetzt mal ein doktorat in spittal
und
denn ich sehe woche dixie und man hat
die rowdys gegen die angst zu stein
geworden sind und dann hat man auch der
entscheid gemacht
mein glück war dass ein platz frei wurde
nicht so schlau ist eine
selbstverständlich das ist schwierig ich
weiß nun was sie vor kurzem hatte sie
gesagt weißt du gar keine grüne
es war schön gemein sie selber
entscheiden
ist da was für die us-tochter auch wenn
wir das tun sie war schon stück für
stück immer wieder mich trifft es gab es
ist schwierig ein stück für stück immer
mehr erlöst ja jetzt momentan ist ja
wieder der phase was ich halt merkt und
das stresst sie auch li und wir könnten
mitmachen
er hat die hilflosigkeit das ist einfach
mit dem umzug zum ziel dass man ein
mensch verliert
hast du ihre arbeit studieren völlig
banal aber dass sie weiß wie immer
findet also dass wir für sie da sind
ich hoffe dass mir mit den sachen für
sich entschieden und jeden urlaubers
qualität
das ist für mich dass ich immer noch als
lager für mich wohl ab und fertig das
finde ich wichtig
[Musik]
min dritter morgen wieder soweit und ich
würde mich auf den fleck station gern
nützlich machen bis ich bin jetzt ganz
schnell an über überblick sie hat alles
mag ich muss schnell zum bäcker zum teil
wie es noch im bett genau wenn ich jetzt
sage sektor nach oben und ich sehe ich
nehme im farbton immer sitzt die ganze
macht eigentlich nie langweilig oder
doch momentan beschäftigen oder also ich
glaub mir halt auch als person immer wie
das bedürfnis mit beschäftigen also
grüßen sitzt denn der letzte parteitag
sitzt eine frau klammer sie sieht
einfach da und wirklich cannabis kann
ich was mache ich jetzt dann bildlich
ihren zivil und wenn ja begangen teilte
cm so quasi dann muss ich lernen musste
dass ich jetzt einfach da ging durch die
vier leute die sind jetzt im smart weil
sie sind beziehen kann ich bin immer das
gefühl ich muss die griffe und jetzt
irgendwie muss er bis machen oder ich
muss eine reaktion auslösen
[Musik]
die jungen akzeptieren dass demenz ein
mensch und sind bedürfnis verändert auch
wenn das für usn gesundem einmal schwer
nachvollziehbar ist
[Musik]
einfach da sie uns mit genannt ganz im
moment lebe das ist das wo die miet
nehme noch dreck im heim für menschen
mit demenz auch wenn sich alles auflöst
und der bau ist in ihre eigene welt
versinkt das bedürfnis noch nie
das blieb das leben nahm dem einziges
thema wo sich tief bewegt bisher
gespannt auf eure fragen und anregungen
zu dem thema für mona mittendrin und
andere talksendung abonnieren